We saw earlier how we could prove correctness, and correctness is easy to show.
Proving security is really hard.
This property of the one-time pad that we can change the key and that leads
to a different message, is the reason why it is secure.
But first I want to talk about how to prove security in general.
Then we'll come back to the problem of how do we prove that the one-time pad
is actually a perfect cipher.
How can we argue that a cipher is secure?
This is a really hard problem.
I'm going to start with a quiz, and it will definitely require some guesswork.
See if you think it through before I explain the answer.
I'm going to give you give possible ways someone might argue
that a cipher is secure.
For this quiz, your goal is to order the arguments below
by how effective they are in convincing someone that a cipher is secure.
Use 1 to indicate the best argument and 4 to indicate the worst argument.
The choices are many very smart people were highly-motivated to break
the cipher but were not able to.
That means it must be secure.
The second choice is there are 834 quadrillion possible keys, so it must be secure.
The third choice here is a mathematical proof that's been accepted by experts
that shows the cipher is secure.
The forth choice is here is a strong argument why breaking the cipher
is at least as hard as some problem we already believe is hard.
This is a bit of a unfair question, since we haven't talked about this yet.
I think it's useful for you to think about it on your own before I talk about it.
See if you can figure out which of these arguments are most effective.